how many's the time hey how are Abby saw
[ __ ] I'll let's just go t she's that's
right we're going down the elevator that
should be fun
oh god dammit I haven't even started yet
you dumb ball of dumb okay
let's freakin go brush let's go brush oh
yeah I don't remember anything besides
this point I remember if we get to touch
a grippers nipple and I think that's all
that really matters technically can I
jump off here no I can't all right well
so far so good
no one is dying
nothing like going deeper and darker
into god dammit god dammit how I changed
my mind I have officially changed my
okay okay please someone
all I bet you it was attack barrels wake
up in the morning feeling like P D PI in
2018 everybody there we go this is cool
oh god that's Frank yeah I was gonna go
there regardless don't worry about it
oh god it's the scariest part I forgot
oh god isn't a I didn't do nothing come
on stone just get out stop wasting my
time
alright peril analysis so many comments
so many comments we're all about the
barrel flip that I did you actually
saved my life thank you people people
like oh he did a barrel flip and he
didn't even talk about it it can't be
that hard I can't seem to do it again
honestly I kind of want to try and oh
god oh god what am I
I think we're fine oh that would have
been sick yeah yeah now you have to
smash like on the video Oh doesn't it
see lightning doesn't strike twice this
is what I've been talking about no god
this is honestly one of the worst parts
in the game this was the first time that
I saw the monster for the first time
when I played it so you can I think I
played it for like four hours or
something that I had to meet four or
five hours to get to this part right
Thank You mr. chair and I had just been
so diligent to make sure I don't run
into him so I had so much fear of the
unknown just built up and then what
happened was I went in here I think no
it was one of these similar rooms and I
I don't know if I wore my headphones the
wrong way or what happened but I heard
him and I went inside the room backwards
I'm explaining this very poorly but it's
oh it's a worse scare of my life I'm not
kidding like I've never been so scared
my life it's like I think the monsters
over there I open the door
then I hear a noise the monsters in the
room but I'm like oh [ __ ] he's over
there so I go in like this we'll get to
that reaction later but oh my god that
were scared by life I don't think I've
ever been that scared and I'm walking in
circles now I'm sorry I got a little
sidetracked
[ __ ] some dark I can't lift those
yeah [ __ ] I hate you I hate I [ __ ]
hate you you're not my bro you're not my
bro you're not my bro bro no no no no
this is an epic epic Oh God [ __ ] no
no
gasps
oh Jesus
oh you've done it now PewDiePie
stop hitting me stop hitting me stop
hitting me
there's no way he's still after me chase
us Christ
I'm Jason Bourne forgot how easy that is
to jump into it how did I like how did I
manage to make it that far I don't
understand
see there oh there's the other one
that's the new one well we use a hammer
right I really can't waste any more oil
and I need to take it more slowly what
what we're mayor fun
why you can go through barrels now close
it
Oh God Jesus Christ yeah I will I will
carry on [ __ ] I hate this part it's too
intense I'm stupid for any trying this I
just
all right shut up its corroded and weak
all right so we smash it
the lock is very career what huh must be
something else then haha
ironically we find that now all right so
there must be something in here yeah I
know something's wrong
quite Daniel quiet hey how did I do that
that was the best flip I've ever seen in
my life
again please oh all right so no stop
playing tricks on me I'm not afraid I'm
a main
is that freakin bread dude let's get
this bread ignored not even the mice 1c
alright Brad you're coming with me
for the rest of the game let's get let's
get it I remember Gabriella
that is no Christian all right let's go
bread
it's you and me bread I love you I love
you too PewDiePie
let's get it this braid it's too narrow
alright let's chip it yeah bread is with
me let's freakin do it let's get this
bread bread where are you red hello
you must have walked further in bread
bread are you there
which way did he go over here what left
okay I'm going this I got bamboozled my
brain everybody said rhyme oh it's in
Swedish Oh
Ladue lula da king kill karna cough
cough Alana Alana stuff okay it's left
that was probably wrong anyway but it
doesn't matter for real though he was my
only friend he was my light in the
darkness
how could he how could he possibly have
made it this far by himself red where
are you I swear I'll find him my love
kollene back Cucina words go and make
this pasta bread let's make a bread my
bread excellent I'm so happy to see 1839
I have arrived at the village of old dad
all just risen in the midst of a vast
forest at the last stop before my final
destination castle brennenburg it's late
in the evening and the outrider
who has been with the coaches it's
Bremen advised me to wait until morning
before I venture further
I've arranged for a bed add a mullah the
villages only in London names they came
I went on to write I tried to sleep but
if I close my eyes I see the man who
fell victim in London my fear and shame
forces me to witness the same scenes
over and over they are dead because of
me well you know you're living you die
alright there you go look at that wait
there's many brain how do I know which
one is authentic only true bread when
please please it's ok I trust you that's
right only real bread will land upwards
fake bread please
I am the real brain don't do it Felix I
love you oh my god oh yeah
it's big time I waited eight years oh
yeah oh yeah I don't know Mike I don't
know about you food how do I wrote I
know I swear I could rotate I don't know
about your pitch but I'm freaking pumped
to see you again man how you been man oh
good yeah you like that you like I'm
still sexy right oh yeah oh yeah you
like that you like this sexy body oh
yeah you wanna cook me don't you oh
that's alright you can do it yeah that's
right slimy slimy and slowly oh that's
right
oh thank you boots
whoa hey it's party time did it did it
dude dude no dude all right so what was
my actual goal I need to make like a hex
true oh you make the bread I know this
like a note that tells you maybe it's
further down the road all right let's go
back here later okay that's bad
but what the hell dude
I'll make it bread in here I'm making
bread in here save me piggy save me
piggy goddamn it
I'm turning this game off he is he fun
if he finds me here hey look we're fine
everybody let's just crawl back no
problem no problem at all
okay so we've been chilling in the
kitchen so I forgot how you open
there's no Momentis well that's not good
that means we're clearly missing
something so this way was the kitchen
and down there it's a secret entrance so
there must be something over here
yeah there the receptacle um let's go
let's go get it let's go get this bread
that's fine
you need help is that bread bread is
that you right
stay right there bread all right let's
go to a receptive column I'm coming for
you buddy
we're septic alum everybody
yeah this is the bit I'll never forget
this bit ever Jesus because you go in
here and you read this stupid no worries
now great brennenburg is a majestic
creation perched upon a forest clad hill
with towers reaching well above even the
highest pine trees following the winding
road leading to the gates
if the impression of discovering
something forgotten as if journeying
with Marco Polo to the Hidden Xanadu
Xanadu Xander the Baron is a peculiar
but gracious man man he once did
well-versed in worldly matters and is
not at all as eccentric as I assumed my
room is exquisite and I'm confident that
no hotel for miles could even hope to
match it Wow as the Sun sets on
brennenburg its fairytale varnish turns
to an eerie gloom Alexander's strange
servants are never far away they are a
quiet lot and their behavior could only
be described as skulking Alexander seems
pleased by my presence as he puts it it
seems like I got here just in time
interesting I forgot about this so now
if you touch that stupid door
how's my son debuting there'll be enough
time bro
be cool
oh my god oh my god oh my holy [ __ ]
fellas jesus [ __ ] christ
oh my god oh my [ __ ] god oh Jesus
Jesus oh my holy oh this game
who's gonna give me a heart attack that
was the most horrible thing ever
holy [ __ ] I can't do this anymore he
will be in there yeah
sorry bro I'm not going
so we'll be ready
it's fine Oh God I got that I'm so
scared now look I lost my sanity I don't
know if it uncovers actually I need to
drink a lot in them okay so we got one
of these this is so annoying I don't
know why they added this because it just
makes you like sick yeah it's almost
like I need to die on purpose to get
this away it's really stupid how do they
do that that's probably one of the
biggest flaws of the game as I would say
excellent condition Oh
all right yeah he broke down the door
what an [ __ ] and there's not nothing
even in here that's the best part
oh I had latinum okay perfect
should be a little better now
yeah there you go look oh of course of
course I don't even have to cook
anything I remember now leave me alone
I'm making cake bread cake again Jesus
Christ it's my bread did we cook it or
it's his acid gödel acid we should just
drink it honestly that's what I would
have done it's been like all right it's
been real but bright ain't worth it no
no you cannot roll me like that you
cannot throw me like that
okay surely now he's gone shut up shut
up
I don't care I don't care I don't care I
don't care whatever virgins idiots but
donk a donk
badonkadonk oh yeah domani time's right
there okay so kitchen now we go to the
recipe room that's right I'm bringing
carpet with me just in case thank you
for being a with me [ __ ] no one really
picks up a carpet these days okay that's
cool I know you like bread okay I know
you're his favorite but I think we could
have some good times you never had a
good time with a carpet before
kind of plucking all my view sorry there
you go
very nice why it's okay it's okay just
put me down and I'll protect you
there you go that's right that's perfect
like they like that I'm not supposed to
be here [ __ ]
just close the door Felix hurry okay
so ridiculous I freaking told you Felix
thank you carpet so much people don't
appreciate carpet these days okay so now
you add the acid it would be no good
what are you kidding me
are you kidding me which door is it then
I don't know could it be could it be oh
yeah because he Brooks hmm ah this must
be it yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
smashed I'm great
Oh
oh [ __ ] you dude
get the hell out of here oh yeah
oh god carpet carpet okay my bad I'm
leaving you behind carpet the carpet not
bad hey it was like a father to me I
loved him like a child
Hey look we're here now most the time so
you use the drain sewers as a means of
transport yes they will to divert water
from an underground spring greased quite
spacious it seemed only natural to
incorporate it into the overall
structure but we won't be easy not today
flow is seasonal and when the spring
test-drive the dead tunnels produce a
rather poisonous we're almost there this
is a really cool area I forgot about
this they really they really did a good
job designing puzzles I don't know it's
cool Oh goddess of water monster here oh
god it's too deep
alright so we need to drain it though
okay
well it's pretty impressive for a castle
to have this so I I don't know I thought
I remember that you had to like throw
something at the ladder maybe I'm wrong
greased
because this is in the way hmm
I don't know
I honestly oh here we go
convenient glass jar that we can use to
grease let's greet sit up baby that's my
catchphrase in life huh now it's dammit
god dammit we were so close the broken
pipe is blocking whoever it's someone's
damaged so now you throw that's why yeah
we do it again of course
Hulk smash yeah alright the lighter is
me and the pipe is t-series watch this
guys take this got him got him that's
what you get t-series yeah that's every
day you climb ladders
surprisingly in the
wonder where I should go all right oh I
feel tall
so now of course what we do is we we hit
this one and then we hit that one and
that lowers what is his message all
right
and then whoa three oh god don't do that
note to self we enter the cyst sister
sister sister
that's right Oh in this area as well
this game has so many other
[Applause]
eggs-actly what is he up to I don't
remember coming for your Alexander you
put patata yeah that's a word okay I
really like to waste my lantern guys I
don't know a faint murmur history the
line hello are you in there
empty chamber
well he can't can't be empty then can it
I think this is another one of those
where you have oh no what was that oh
Jesus Christ what's wrong with me okay I
think we're fine actually oh thank god
look we're fine thought I was a gunner
just get up just just get up
just get up Felix there you go good job
buddy it's not a skillful jumping in
this game you have to be really good at
jumping just like I am extremely I'm not
surprised even while traveling across
Europe I assumed I would have to embrace
the supernatural to save my mind and
life as a novice I do everything in my
power to stay focused and not dwell too
much on my own doubts
Alexander woke me up early he told me it
was time we got started on our work he
was obviously excited Ashley headed
downstairs to the old dungeon where he
preferred to attempt his rituals his sex
dungeon you know in that's relative by
DaVinci I'm sure he showed me several
rooms fitted a specific research such as
Anatomy studied dead dogs and botany the
crown of brennenburg must be the inner
sanctum a most hallowed ground where we
shall attempt to permanently banish the
orbs shadow
alright let's spin oh yeah
I don't think that's good just a guess I
don't think I did anything good there
but you never know
you got to remain optimistic oh god oh
god I'm sorry buddy
I'm sorry may you know I didn't Oh geesh
hey I hope t-series is in there hey
listen are you okay just tell me hello
okay that's good all right well these
things happen you know you live some you
lose some
that's what I always say so where do I
go from here there's no way they're not
having the water monster in here I do
not believe it well we got a little with
that ladder how do we do that then
although am I supposed to do this
throw my hammer all right nope don't
work didn't think it would
oh maybe I can just
maybe throw on their throne things
usually works in this game IQ 5 million
I bet you were like a rabbit they don't
work oh really oh really didn't it I
didn't do it I did it I mean I mean I
okay alright look at this dude look at
this using my orb
Alexandre managed to channel its power
unto us I feel like the orb is is
another word for sex and he makes this
game scarier it was like standing in a
mad world pool of impressions it was
terrifying
but Alexander kept calm just change all
of with Venus tools of science in order
to tame the storm the blue light was
stained by strains of red and the walls
burst with pulsating tissue resonating
with the scene ok exam gross they
covered the orb in some cloth and the
couple things the shadow is closer than
he said I should prepare for a warding
ritual tomorrow now I can't I can't stop
imagining it and yeah damn it alright
let's spend time spend time spend time
yeah we did
okay it's this where the monster comes I
don't remember
okay come on don't frickin mess up now
feeler okay so I think I think that was
both for them shut up shut your mouth
boy oh it's over there as well
you know god damn it how did we get
there I think we have to throw a rock or
something no was that not him huh all
right well let's just go then Hey look
there's a fish that's happening okay so
now we just gotta
I'd spend time spend time oh yeah hey
trying to fake me out boy okay he's
definitely in there it is still early
and Alexander is busy preparing for the
ritual later today seeing if this worked
up makes me question why what does he
stand to gain I realize he is curious
about it all but surely there must be
more this is fate
foolish he will attempt to tame them the
power yesterday when Alexander flooded
the inner sanctum with blue light I
realized we had but graced the orbs this
might turn out to be more than a shadow
it might be the beginning something oh
my god I can't unsee it now stop stop
okay Oh
spend time
whoo five burger baby oh yeah that was
epic thank you thank you thank you thank
you tango tango tango oh god oh god oh
shoot
so I think we're done here
they should have designed this puzzle
differently so that when you were done
with it you had to like go through with
him on sir that would have been cooler
just in my opinion I don't all right so
we are back here that's cool now I think
what we can do is we can use these right
now wait we'd already done those well
then I Oh could it be that we drained
the pipe so we can go down there now
well we shall see
hope tea service doesn't scratch my
thing okay here we go
what if I just greased myself up you
know ah ah and then when the monster
hits me you won't be able to grab me see
ah Jesus
oh yes a fungus thing is that gonna kill
me nah it's fine
oh god I'm gonna die I'm gonna die
I need a vaccine oh okay
find a vaccine are you really asking for
a lot here aren't you
I don't remember that
we never went in the control-room did we
oh my god oh my god this part this
fricking part come on all right like
this
deep flavors an old friend back it out
to you however it seems great
and
was I talking about
come on move
there you go muscle salt I spent so much
time in hearing doing this puzzle I
remember I did a full episode just me
like going back and forth and everyone
was just losing their mind I think
there's a right order to do this for it
to go all the way down like oh my god
that was easy
I hoped I did not take me along
and then we put the winning crank
somewhere I don't remember where you
don't need to wait say oh yeah there's a
missing pipe here that needs to be
changed that you need to find somewhere
see I'm good all right don't worry this
is the pasta solving skills can I just
do this all right listen we got a new
pipe hey piers I think I could be the
next character in your aneasha series
all right sure you got the part
oh god oh god oh no oh thank god I have
to hammer you out did I find a pipe too
early do I need to stop the flow first
maybe the work I have put into the news
machine is unequaled by the reasoning of
any man the thought that generation of
men have passed away since I first
attempted to reconstruct the design is
most tiring this is a great but the
limitation of this world have made my
work incredibly difficult it has forced
me to build the thing almost a hundred
times larger than the delicate
contraption it tries to emulate not to
mention the flow of tame lightning
crudely replaced by pressured steam
pushing it its way through the pipes and
turbines it shames me to think that of
what the interior would have a thought
of my monster inventor I'm stupid where
he works with a magnifying glass to
carefully fix all the part I push five
men to erect up a tower of broad in iron
in the hope it will have even the
tiniest hint of power found in a
traveler's login okay so I think what we
need to do
so to add it's stuck why
sheesh
okay there's something here another pipe
might be useful later and we have these
things maybe a clue right now there's no
clues great it's fine
why
what is that effect
what does this do
goddamnit I take it all back I'm a
[ __ ] idiot his must have done
something
was this here before
maybe needs to be balanced so maybe one
of them is stuck maybe this one is stuck
oh there you go so I need to balance it
out okay so one of them is just the
height of that pipe and okay well no
wonder this took me forever Jesus Christ
oh it's the pipes over here there you go
okay I got it okay guys this is epic
okay so the last one goes I guess you
just put them randomly I don't I don't
know
it's all about balance I guess the
puzzles did I put them their own order I
don't know
possibly
yeah look oh yeah they come off okay I
see look I did it guys
there must be one more pipe then I'm
missing a pipe must be hiding somewhere
where are you pipe there you go
okay now I think the only thing is to
match yeah yeah you know what are you
doing so I think I heard a sound before
oh my god I was so close
are you kidding me alright so what does
this mean then alright well I did
something so let's go out and check it
out
oh and now the second one comes down
dammit you'll need a push like why
all right net maybe now oh of course of
course
oh yeah all right
oh yeah oh there this is gonna be
freakin awesome let's go brow alright we
did it on that note I'm gonna end that
episode there hope you guys enjoy this
episode if you did any support is
appreciated like smash subscribe and all
that stuff and I'll see you guys the
next one